قربنا كتير خلصنا من نص الشهر
ومعظم الاعمال خاصه اللي مكمله معنا لاخر
الشهر خلاص قطعت نصها وحبكتها والقصه
والمضمونه توضحت مع كل هذا طبعا في رده
فعل كمان فيعني في ردود الفعل الى حد كبير
اللي تكونت سواء من ناحيه المشاهدين او من
ناحيه النقاد اللي وزع كثير منهم ولو
مبدئيا يعني القاب الافضل الاسوا
المحظوظين الاقل حظا ومثل ما عودناكم كل
سنه تفاعلكم لازم يعمل كده في النص الشهر
جرد مبدئي وبيساعدنا في اليوم ضيفنا من
القاهره الناقد الفني محمد عبد الرحمن
اهلا فيك معانا وكل عام طبعا بالف خير
خلينا نبتدي من البدايه ونقول كالمسم سيء
ام جيد بشكل عام
يعني اهلا بك ساره وبدون مجاملات يعني
مستمتع بمعظم التخطيات اللي بتحصل في
تفاعلكم واللي بتاكد ان الموسم جيد
مش كلها
ما هو لو قلت كلها يبقى كده يعني
الموضوعيه مش موجوده معلش خليك في موضوعي
احنا ما بنحب الموضوعيين يا محمد
عايزاني ابقى موضوعي في مجدي المسلسلات بس
بس احنا لا ههه
يعني الموسم بدايه صعبه اول يومين كان في
حمله جديده خالص على الدراما المصريه ما
حصلتش قبل كده ان يبقى فيه نوع من انواع
التحفيط او اللي هو انه يتقال ان
المسلسلات مش جيده لكن سرعان ما ده تم
تخطيه وبقى فيه يعني ما لا يقل عن عشر
مسلسلات فيها عامله متابعه جيده جدا اه في
مسلسلات اقل متابعه لكن من خلال تجربتنا
في الشارع المصري يمكن مش كل المسلسلات
اللي عامله زخم على السوشيال ميديا مش
موجوده في الشارع بالعكس في مسلسلات
موجوده كتير في الشارع لكن مش موجوده على
السوشيال ميديا كمان احنا بنتكلم على
موسمين احنا بكره او بعده هتبدا ثلاث اربع
مسلسلات
يعني ثقيلات بالصدفه معظمهم ستات يعني هي
15 حلقه منى زكاه متوقع المسلسل
نعم منى زكي الصندوق لاحمد
من شلبي
قد سليمه دنيا سمير غانم كمان ايضا يمكن
يعني في كثير اسماء فعلا مرتقبه بس طيب
محمد لما بيعني اعطيني اسامي مين اللي اكل
الجو هذا الموسم
الاكل الجو على المستوى
الجماهير في الصحافه طبعا جعفر العمده
بشكل كبير عامل نجاحات تراكميه ان كان
تحافظتنا الفنيه او النقديه على المسلسل
فهو عامل يعني عامل شغل كويس على السوشيال
ميديا الهارشه السابعه والصفاره برضو
عاملين ردود افعال ايجابيه
بعد مرحله الاستكشاف يعني فيعتقد دول من
اكتر المسلسلات اللي عاملين يعني رد فعل
كويس جدا
الاسماء اللي ذكرتها حتى على يعني ممكن
انا لانه بتابع يعني
السوشيال ميديا يعني الخليجيه والسعوديه
يمكن اكثر شيء برضه هذه المسلسلات اللي
ذكرتها وخصوصا جعفر العمده يعني ضارب بشكل
كبير طبعا وايضا المسلسلات الثانيه اللي
ذكرتها
السابعه يمكن كمان اكثر
النجاح مستحيل انه يستخبى ايوه ايوه لا لا
ما فعلا هذه انا اوافقك الراي فيها تماما
محمد رمضان محمد سامي في جعفر العمده
السندي مكسرين الدنيا ما فيها جدال او
نقاش يعني طيب مين اللي غير موفق اللي غير
موفق يعني في محمد سعد
الفيدباك على مسلسل ضعيف جدا المقاطع اللي
انا شفتها او يعني سالت حتى استعمال
النهارده قبل ما اطلع معكم ما فيش يعني
وكانه مسلسل مش موجود برضو ما اظنش انا ما
اتفرجتش بس تجربه سهير رمزي ما عجبتش فيه
كويس ده لو اتكلمنا على فكره ان المسلسل
يمر كان لم يكن يعني انه لا يحسب في بعض
المسلسلات التانيه يمكن التوقعات فيها اقل
من من اللي كان يعني
محسوب مسلسل الفنانه يسرا يعني مقارنه الف
حمد لله على السلامه
السنه اللي فاتت احلام سعيده لا السنه
اللي فاتت تكسب ولكن بيظل طبعا اليسرى
جمهور عريض بيتابعها وده واضح يعني من
متابعات السوشيال ميديا لكن مش بنفس الزخم
اللي كان متوقع اوكي طيب اللي الناس اللي
نقول السنه دي برزوا لانه رمضان دايما
عندنا كم اسم خلص بينجموا بصي انا دايما
بقول ان احنا
عندنا مستويات بس دايما عندنا ملزون من
الممثلين على كل من كل الاعمار بيبقى جيد
جدا في مفاجات السنه دي وده بيخلينا نوصل
لمسلسل تاني برضو من مسلسلات اللي عامله
صدى جيد وان ما كانش عامل الباز الكبير هو
عمره نادله عمره نادره
يعني الفنان احمد عيد الفنان احمد عيد هو
من مفاجات الموسم زي ما بيقولوا في كره
القدم كده الحصان الاسود
هو كمان حد جاي بعد فتره ثمان سنين من
الغياب عند الكرامه وعامل شخصيه يعني بعيد
عنه خالص فطبعا يعني عامل اداء جيد جدا
والاشادات هو نفسه قال لي يعني انا حاسس
ان شداد في فيها مبالغه من كتر ما هو حاسس
ان هو لان الناس متعودين عليه في الكوميدي
كمان فصدمهم هو ده اللي عامل يعني عامل
كمان الشهاده الاكبر هو مش بس راجع بعد
غياب باداء كويس لا كمان باداء تراجيدي
باداء شرير اول مره يقتل ويقتل اخوه يعني
دي كلها حاجات عمره ما عملها قبل كده هو
ربح الرقاق افضل الفنانه مي كساب
جعفر العمده وده برده بيوقفنا عامله فعلا
اداء شخصيه ثريا بشكل جميل جدا
ومجتهده ولابسه الدور كويس وهنا في نقطه
برده في خلطه محمد سامي ومحمد رمضان انه
حتى لو المسلسل فيه مبالغات في نوع من
انواع اللي احنا بنسميه المواقف الدراميه
الهنديه يعني عشان بيحصل ده لكن هذا صدقي
عامله حاله يعني فيها شبه اجماع على
الاداء اللي هي صح كانت فاسنه ويعني
صعب اوصف قديش هي رائعه ما يكسر كانت
ضيفتنا صعب اوصف قديش هي رائعه برضه
عاملين اداء حتى منه فضالي برمانيه حضورها
الفني بقى له فتره متذبذب لكن عامله فعلا
شخصيه كويسه لبنى وانس لما الناس بتطلع
وتشيك بيها وهي في اخر دورها دور محوري اه
بس مش مساحه كبيره ده معناه ان الناس اولا
تتفرج بتتفرج ومش بتتفرج على كذا عنصر في
العمل مش بس على انا ما اظنش ان في عمل
السنه دي ناجح عشان نجمه
ناصب جذب الانتباه
اخر شيء بس قلتم انه ما تظن انه في عمل
ايه اه ما فيش مسلسل مش ناجي عشان محمد
رمضان لوحده ولا مسلسل الهرشه راجع عشان
امينه خليل ولا الصفاره ناجح بس عشان احمد
امين
[موسيقى]
متكامله
ويسرا مش متراجع عشان اداء يس حلو جدا بس
هو في مشكله في الدراما في المصداقيه
الاحداث فهو ده اللي عمل يعني مشكله ورق
مش مشكله خليني بس سريعا محمد بدي اسالك
عن المسلسلات اللي هي ما فيها لا ضرب ولا
كده يعني الصفاره الهرش السابعه هذا النوع
من المسلسلات فجاه لقينا ناس كثير مرتاحه
وهي بتتفرج مش متوتره
هو انا بصراحه
عنده المصداقيه يعني وهم بيتفرجوا عارفين
ده ما بيحصلش في الشارع اصلا
محمد رمضان بيضرب احد احنا نضربه اوكي
الفكره انه في فئه كبيره من الناس كمان
خصوصا اللي بحب يتفرجوا عن طريق المنصات
مش اللي بيتفرجوا على المقاهي او في
مشاهدات جماهيريه شويه او عدد كبير بيحب
يشوف حاجه هاديه فبيحس يعني انا احس انه
مسلسلين الهرش السابعه
والصفاره وايضا مذكرات
زوجين للطبقه المتوسطه اللي عايزه تشوف
نفسها النجاح